le swing et à la lampe frontale avec une
balle clignotantes une expérience
inédite au golf national en vue de la
ryder cup 2018 et des sensations pour le
moins perturbante pour ses licenciés
pourtant joueurs aguerris du ferveur
c'est assez surprenant
les sensations sont totalement
différentes la perception de la
géographie du terrain est absolument
impossible à avoir et donc on joue un
petit peu un petit peu à l'aveuglé les
repères s'en vont le point d'arrivée
reste dans l'obscurité et même les plus
courtes distances comme opting s'avère
très tortueuse pour les plus frileux
un simulateur de drive était aussi
installé dans le club house les
participants pouvaient aussi s'essayer
au swing virtuel sur les consoles de
jeux vidéo mais rien ne vaut le club
dans la main c'est plus difficile de
jouer à la console pour moi mais je
pense qu'à aussi jouer de nuit là comme
on l'a fait pour la première fois c'est
pas du tout simple c'est très amusant
mais c'est quand même il faut il faut
être habitué c'est dès maintenant que la
ryder cup se prépare au golf national
plus de six millions d'euros sont prévus
pour aménager le parcours et le rendre
plus spectaculaire
un parcours que devrait fouler les
joueurs français après le titre mondial
chez les amateurs en 2010 la mission qui
leur est donné par le comité directeur
et par moi bien sûr ses délires les
enfants on à la ryder cup
mais si on a pas de français dans
l'équipe européenne
il y en a que douze membres
c'est une équipe réduite dans les
meilleurs européens on aura raté quelque
chose
en attendant d'avoir un français dans
l'équipe européenne en 2018
certains risquent de jouer jusqu'au bout
de la nuit